we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p here's another viewer
who has a parent that they are
struggling with when it comes to
politics and media but this is a little
bit of a different problem than one
we've heard before take a listen to this
david
i know you get these calls all the time
yeah how do i get my mother off of fox
news
i mean she's not so radical that she
believes in chewing on and all this
other crazy crap but i can't get her to
turn off fox news
it's like
it's just insane man i mean as soon as i
leave the house she turns the [ __ ] on
i mean
anyway
i try to point out to her
you know how wrong they are
and then you know things happen i go
remember i told you they were wrong
about that and you know and i told her i
said see i'm i'm right about 90 percent
of stuff and and fox news is wrong about
90 of stuff
but i can't get her to turn it off
anyway
thanks love you so man you do a great
job thank you well so listen this this
is tough persistent fox news watching
can be a hard habit to break or a hard
addiction to break
um one of the things i would suggest
because it sounds like your mom is
really pretty deep into it
instead of immediately trying to get her
off of fox
what i would suggest is just that she
diversify the media diet oftentimes with
these situations you want to take the
path of least resistance and the path of
least resistance initially might be
saying hey
don't go after her and say never watch
fox news again but it might be
add this or that to your media diet
check out the pbs newshour or maybe
watch you know what get more variety in
your media diet maybe read something
would be an interesting one as well
though not not everybody reads
consider that the first step and you
know think about it like someone who's
addicted to uh i don't imagine someone
every morning has one of those sugary uh
toaster strudels i don't even know if
those are around but i remember when i
was a kid that was like the epitome or
like a pop-tart or something okay
um and please if you work for those
companies don't sue me i'm just saying
they have a lot of sugar imagine someone
every single day has a toaster strudel
with extra powdered sugar and maple
syrup and all this stuff on it's like
okay that's really bad but if we just go
in and we say just stop just stop cold
turkey no more toaster strudels you can
understand how it'd be very difficult to
get that person to say okay sure no more
toaster strudels what do they replace it
with so if that was what i was dealing
with i might first go in and go hey you
know what
um
it might be interesting just for
diversity you know to try different
things if one morning a week instead of
the toaster strudel you instead get a
piece of beautiful multi-grain toast
and then spread some avocado on it with
some spicy chili oil
oh okay well now we've got an
alternative you're not saying drop the
toaster strudel you're saying have six
toaster strudels a week and have one
piece of avocado toast and then if that
goes okay you go hey you know what
there's so many great breakfasts
what if one morning you had a bowl of
greek yogurt with sliced up berries and
a no sugar granola it's delicious so now
you've got five to and then later you
can go hey you know it's how are you
feeling by the way you
you feeling any better now that you're
introducing some other and you get the
point okay so this is the same thing i
would suggest with fox news i would say
hey you know there's so many different
media outlets out there variety is good
what if one morning you listen to npr's
fresh air instead of watching fox and
friends or whatever the case may be
start there
and then see where that gets you and you
know
uh it's an uphill battle for sure but
that's probably with someone who's
really addicted that's probably where i
would start we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today as i mentioned
earlier a judge has dismissed mike
pillow's countersuits against smartmatic
and dominion voting machine
manufacturers
and
we are going to talk about what's going
on pillow is also being asked to pay
smartmatics attorneys fees which is just
beautiful republicans are vowing to kill
the domestic terrorism bill currently
being discussed in the senate why i'll
tell you and an archbishop of the
catholic church is barring nancy pelosi
from receiving communion
because of her support for abortion
rights we've talked before
about catholic elected officials and
abortion and communion in the context of
joe biden
we will also talk about it today in the
context of nancy pelosi get instant
access and i do mean instant by signing
up for the bonus show at joinpackman.com
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad thank you alex
and also if you would like a discount
off of the cost of a membership get on
my newsletter at davidpakman.com
you will thus get an email on monday
memorial day telling you how to take
advantage of a beautiful membership
discount see you then or tomorrow